foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you're impossible because I found a
safe place for us to live
I wanted
to see the world
[Music]
for no reason except a chance at a
Caribbean vacation I don't want to miss
out on life because you're afraid to
leave this pond
here we go
why are we the only Birds heading this
way
[Applause]
I promised adventure and this is exactly
what I promised
it's you with Laurence on top
you're old enough to do it in the sky
now we have a number two situation oh
but it's gross every bird does it in the
sky
told you we are not Landing there is no
way we're Landing
when Mallard do it now or we leave
without you okay okay
foreign
it's this way well we are not flying
through this crazy death trap of a city
just stay close to me and everything
will be all right
I'm okay yeah no I'm okay we can do this
maybe you don't stick too close